I'm Danny Danny very good to meet you
dude I'm Josh how do you rate yourself
as a dancer
say about uh 7.25
can I say I love the [ __ ] straight up
confidence
the Precision of the number
tells you he's confident exactly how
good I am 7.25
yep and I'm not going to ask you how big
your dick is because I bet you no
all right
[Applause]
one word
scribe your dance style 90s cornball 90s
cornball
[Applause]
what is the
you know that Little John song plays you
know the get it low yeah
I could get pretty low you get pretty
low yeah
hey by the way yeah by the way I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna lie to you I'm not
gonna lie to you you said I get pretty
low even the dudes in here got a little
movement like oh okay
that's Hammer who are you with I'm here
with my best friend Marisa all right oh
that's nice no on this side on this side
oh no I looked over there I'm good okay
yeah
kind of how pointing and hearing goes I
looked at him yeah
okay now let me ask you something rate
yourself as a dancer one through ten
consolidate
yo I gotta tell you there's some [ __ ]
gauntlets being thrown down here tonight
one word to describe your dance style
funky weird funky weird
hurts to us
[Applause]
hyphenated come on dude don't be a
rookie she hyphenated it
[Applause]
what's the name of your best dance move
stupid
[Music]
can't wait to see that yeah
do you have a better one what do you
have another one you want to go with
stupid
yeah I think we should I'm all in on
stupid okay yeah while you're at this
show you must be so
hey everybody uh
one more time Tamara everybody she's
selling eight
one through ten rate yourself as a
dancer
[Music]
I'd say like a five
no no no no no no no no no this is the
smart I don't have an ass you Price is
Right
dude literally it's literally like you
made a frog stand up in Virginia yeah
really bad foreign
I do squats but it just doesn't work you
you've got an any [ __ ]
[Applause]
it's like your [ __ ] is eating itself
it's like it's going inward like a
Pac-Man
it's just zero ass thanks Mom
[Applause]
now I know the dads like you've got a
great ass honey
laughs
it's perfect for me I love your ass your
ass is the best ass I've ever seen [ __ ]
that kid yeah
you make up in other areas you're good
yeah he definitely doesn't say that
he's still married right yeah he doesn't
say that
okay now what is the name of your best
dance move it's blender
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well I know you're not blending up any
ass yeah
[Applause]
right Mom
[Applause]
love you Mom can I get yeah
dude I told you I would give you a hand
because your parents are here
a lot of times you show a little nip
the crowd responds favorably is all I'm
saying
all I'm saying is you know this is a
crowd response contest skin to win [ __ ]
uh
[Applause]
yeah
but there may be a second round so okay
here we go you can take whatever off you
want however
however however however however the baby
bird stays in the nest
[Applause]
the baby bird stays in the nest and you
can't you can't fling it around it's
just got to be backstage
[Applause]
in front of people you know what I'm
saying
you can give your mama lap dance but I
you have to ask her
all right here we go
you're up ready
[Laughter]
good luck remember no touching me okay
all right
I felt a weird hover energy
what is that
[Applause]
ah here we go
all right man
let's see them titties here we go
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
hold on hold on hold on let me let me
just
let me just take that in for a second
[Applause]
oh you [ __ ] dolphin
[ __ ] watch up oh you can wash up on my
beach anytime
[Applause]
Tamara
are you ready are you ready you're an
eight girl
you're a [ __ ] solid eight
all I'm telling you is just give it some
energy you know make him go what the
[ __ ]
that usually works you ready
all right here we go we got you
I want you to I want I want you to know
something this is 100 true I want you to
know something and this is I should have
said this for all of you but
they want you to do great this is a home
game
this is a home game zero pressure this
is a home this is a home game this is a
home game just have a good time this is
all this is a good time okay okay all
right you ready
all right
[Applause]
here we go
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay here we go everybody
[Applause]
you are
my fire the one these
days
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm telling you home team it's a home
game bro
do whatever the [ __ ]
oh you do whatever you want yeah you do
whatever you want
see what your son started
good good job Mom and Dad
here we go man
there's always one of you at a barbecue
[Applause]
[ __ ] shirt what's up okay
yeah
[ __ ] yeah I do ah here we go man this is
for you here we go
[Music]
you are
on my fire
oh no
[Applause]
I Want It That Way
[Applause]
yo
little front crack and back crack we got
up on that one
[ __ ] two crack attack is what we all
just saw
[ __ ] don't apologize
that's what brings him to the yard dude
come on
[Applause]
[ __ ] yeah is he one crack two crack
Daniel wow
everybody come on come on everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
hey I have had a great time here this
weekend I this has been one of the best
comedy weekends of my life
first of all all three of your servers
win 100.
that's all
but yo this is what I love about the
people who come to my shows man we've
been up here a long time a couple people
left I would assume but you all are here
and still [ __ ] in it
all right listen again so much respect
for you guys make sure that your servers
find me after the show servers see them
I owe you whoever that is a hundred
dollars okay all right everybody one
time let him hear it one time let him
hear one time
what's up
[Applause]
you want to dance for free yeah okay
you were gonna drop travel that does not
incentivize me